[Musik]
wir kommen zu einem kurzen nachrichten
überblick in der halbzeitpause und wir
beginnen in thüringen wo es seit der
wahl im oktober keine klaren
mehrheitsverhältnisse ergibt die
bisherige koalition aus linken spd und
grünen kann nur eine
minderheitsregierung bilden heute große
runde bei ministerpräsident ramelow wo
sich cdu-chef mohring bereit erklärte
der regierung bei bestimmten projekten
die mehrheit zu sichern
daniela sonntag so hatten sie sich noch
nie getroffen rot-rot-grün cdu und fdp
in erfurt damit thüringen regiert bleibt
suchen sie nach einem politischen ausweg
cdu-chef mohring will nun mit einer
minderheitsregierung unter bodo ramelow
kompromisse finden bei einzelnen
projekten
ja aber gleichzeitig gesagt dass wir
gespräche offenheit auch harten und
sagen dass dort mehrheit gesichert
werden wo themen notwendig sind bei
dieses land voranbringen zusammenarbeit
mit den linken die bundes cdu ist strikt
dagegen deshalb keine koalition kein
duldungsvertrag keine gemeinsamen
gremien so soll das thüringer modell aus
kommen um zum beispiel mehr lehrer
einzustellen oder die kommunen besser zu
finanzieren
auch die linke hält das für
grundsätzlich sinnvoll wir arbeiten auf
der basis eine minderheitsregierung und
wenn die cdu sich daran beteiligen
möchte und sei es über projekte diese
minderheitsregierung für stabile
verhältnisse in zürich zu stützen sind
wir offen für gespräche linke spd und
grüne haben ihren koalitionsvertrag fast
fertig wie eine projektarbeit mit cdu
und fdp dazu passt und um welche themen
es gehen kann
das soll nun besprochen werden
ungeachtet aller proteste siemens will
wie geplant die signalanlage für eines
der weltweit grössten kohlebergwerke in
australien liefern auftragsvolumen 18
millionen euro
wir müssen unsere vertraglichen
verpflichtungen erfüllen erklärte
konzernchef joe kaeser vor der
konzernzentrale protestierten
klimaaktivisten von freddys for future
siemens gefährde das ziel die
erderwärmung auf unter zwei grad
einzudämmen
nach berlin aus dem finanzministerium
kommen überraschend positive nachrichten
die regierung nimmt aus dem haushalt
2009 10 einen rekord überschuss in höhe
von 13,5 milliarden euro mit ins neue
jahr
florian hahn mit den einzelheiten mit
diesem rekord hatte wohl selbst olaf
scholz nicht gerechnet ein überschuss
wie in der bund in der jüngeren
geschichte noch nicht erlebt hat wir
hatten ein bisschen glück und natürlich
haben wir auch gut gewirtschaftet das
geld ist auch sinnvoll einsetzbar für
die zukunft verantwortlich für den
überschuss gesunkene zinsen gestiegene
steuereinnahmen neue schulden wie
zuletzt von der spd spitze gefordert
seien daher gar nicht nötig meinen heute
sowohl spd finanzministerium als auch
die union es müssen jetzt die
diskussionen die attacken auf die
schwarze null eingestellt werden wir
können mit dem geld ist wir haben gut
wirtschaften der finanzminister will den
überschuss für investitionen einsetzen
die opposition hat andere ideen
wir wollen dass zum einen die bürger
entlastet werden die bürger und die
betriebe wir wollen den soli vollständig
abschaffen für alle die ihn bisher
gezahlt haben
vor einem jahr hatte olaf scholz noch
gewarnt die fetten jahre seien vorbei
der überschuss von heute spricht eine
andere sprache in ihrer hand die wut auf
die machthaber nicht ab auch heute
gingen wieder zahlreiche menschen auf
die straße
sie werfen der führung vertuschung vor
gestern soll die polizei gewaltsam gegen
demonstranten vorgegangen seien
wie dieses handy video zeigen soll
hintergrund ist der abschuss eines
ukrainischen flugzeugs die regierung
bestritt tage lang dafür verantwortlich
zu sein
auf den philippinen wächst die angst vor
einem gewaltigen vulkanausbruch
zehntausende sind bereits auf der flucht
seit tagen spuckt asche und rauch bis zu
15 kilometer hoch der vulkan liegt
mitten in einem see und ist nur etwa 60
kilometer von der hauptstadt manila
entfernt eine große eruption könnte kurz
bevor stehen waren die behörden
antoine kohler schäden es ist eine
naturgewalt faszinierend und bedrohlich
beim ausbruch produziert der vulkan tal
sein eigenes blitzlichtgewitter die
aschewolke reicht 15 kilometer hoch in
den himmel unten hört sie alles in grau
mit den menschen die luft zum atmen
anwohner fliehen vor der tödlichen kraft
der natur plötzlich hörten wir einen
lauten knall steine und asche krachten
auf unser haus wir hatten fürchterliche
angst als der vulkan ausbrach
bislang wurden mehr als 45.000 menschen
in sicherheit gebracht hunderttausende
könnten es werden
wenn sich die lage weiter verschlimmert
auch die nahe gelegene hauptstadt manila
ist betroffen der internationale
flughafen lahmgelegt vom ascheregen
gestrandete passagiere
hunderte flüge gestrichen mehr als 50
vulkane gibt es auf den philippinen tal
ist einer der aktivsten bei vergangenen
ausbrüchen kamen tausende menschen ums
leben und auch jetzt bleibt die lage
gefährlich seismologen warnen er könnte
noch mal ausbrechen mit weitaus mehr
zerstörungskraft als beim ersten mal
und es gibt noch eine entscheidung der
queen elizabeth die zweite gibt ihren
segen
ihr enkel prinz harry und seine frau
megan dürfen sich aus der ersten reihe
der royals zurückziehen
die queen bedauert zwar den wunsch der
beiden respektiert ihn aber auch genaue
details sind aber noch zu klären
das wetter gleich im anschluss mit katja
horneffer und christian sievers
informiert sie dann nach dem
handballspiel ausführlich im heute
journal um 21.45 viel spaß noch bei der
zweiten halbzeit und bis morgen abend
dann wieder normal um sie
[Musik]
meine damen und herren an winter
erinnern in dieser nach die temperaturen
höchstens mal in bayern denn da sinken
sie in den mäßigen frost von minus 56
grad deutlich milder bleibt die nacht
dagegen am niederrhein und auch im
emsland mit sieben oder acht grad denn
dort beginnt es bereits in der nacht zu
regeln in süddeutschland dagegen ist es
zum teil klar oder es bildet sich nebel
und der wind nimmt auch schon morgens
ging dann die regenwolken vor allen
dingen vormittags über norddeutschland
hinweg und zum abend kann es an der
nordsee richtig stürmisch werden
in süddeutschland dagegen scheint
häufiger die sonne und die temperaturen
liegen morgens zwischen drei grad an der
unteren dunger und 13 grad am oberrhein
und in den nächsten tagen geht es sehr
mild weiter schönen abend noch